laundry mats uh i actually own one in a
very weird way much longer story uh but
we own um a partner and i own uh some of
the real estate and we also own uh some
of the business as well and they print
cash it's crazy
so what is the opportunity you think
from a laundromat and kind of how could
somebody go from i don't know businesses
to getting in this game
yeah it's funny i wrote about that on
twitter and it kind of went a little
viral then everybody's like so what do
you do for a living you just own
laundromats and it's like no that's one
of one of the things i own but but the
um the reason i talk so much about
laundromats is because it's accessible
when i go start talking about buying
businesses most people are like must be
nice privilege and it's like wait a
second wait a second
the reason i talk about buying
businesses is because it has actually
been only done by pe firms for so long
and so we've got to start with a
business that is not so intimidating and
the laundromat it's like you have a
space you lease you have machines that
you utilize people put in quarters and
you print money on the other side of it
you got to clean up the place a little
bit you've got to have somebody do some
maintenance on the machines but it's
really not a lot more than that and so
um i like to talk about laundromats
because like you said they actually they
cash flow beautifully the price for them
probably it's worth a little bit more
now because i've been spouting off about
it for a while but um you know it's
usually two to three x the profit so
when you go to buy a laundromat if a
laundromat makes a hundred thousand
dollars a year you can typically buy
them for 200 or 300 000
and if people are like also sounds great
i don't have 300k lying around they
don't realize there's something called
the sba and the sba the small business
association will give you a loan for 90
of the purchase price of a business that
has books that they can track and
confirm the profits from and so
just like you could go out and buy a
mortgage and put 10 down you could do
that on a business if you were to go and
buy a house right now a single family
with a mortgage and try to cash flow it
the average uh single family makes about
464 dollars a month
464 dollars a month is what you make
from putting down hundreds of thousands
of dollars in a laundromat i'm making
five 10k a month
it's a totally different game yeah it's
incredible mailbox money which is a
great name but what is uh what is
mailbox money how can you do it
yeah you need to have her on she's over
she's a riot uh so so a friend of mine
uh lisa song sutton um is similar to me
we have this idea of buying boring
businesses holding them forever and i
think it's that immigrant hustle she's
uh like first gen korean um but
essentially what it is is so
i was looking at the self storage space
lots of people are i think we're both
friends with nick huber sweaty startup i
was like this looks interesting it's a
way to get into real estate but with a
higher return on that monthly cash flow
we talked about because i'm always like
show me the cash i want to see it every
month but the thing with self storage is
now you got every buddy and their
brother in that space and it's become
overhyped and expensive for the most
part in my opinion
and so i was like so how can we do this
cheaper and i was talking to lisa and
she's like i own this mail center so you
know how you got to ship out a package
you don't always go to fedex or ups you
could go to like cody's shipping center
up the street or something right so i
always thought those businesses were
kind of interesting because the packages
and maybe they make a bunch of money
sending back and forth and all the chat
keys in the store wrong they're real
estate businesses they're mini mailbox
real estate businesses so you charge
anywhere from 20 to 30 to 40 to 50 a
month for a little p.o box and the the
key is ups knows that this is the game
so they mandate that you can only have
like 100 mailboxes in a ups franchise i
hate franchises by the way so i never
buy a ups but if you own your own store
you could cram two hundred three hundred
five hundred a thousand mini little po
mailboxes in there and every single one
you're making twenty to thirty dollars a
month lisa's mailboxes sell out within
six months because everybody and their
brother's doing what we're doing right
we got llc's we got things we need to
send we're starting our side hustles and
so the business is booming but there are
not enough mailboxes that's mailbox
money and so when you think about that
business specifically is it something
where uh it's people in a local area
they come in to the physical location
they like get their mail out of the po
box or is there like a digital component
where then somebody's going into the po
box at the business and like taking a
photo of the mail and then people can
access it online like how kind of
digitally native or or digitally up the
curve are these types of businesses
versus literally just
we have a mailbox you rent it from us
come in get the mail whenever you want
and like leave us alone
yeah most of them are the latter so
digitally native is not normal in small
business at all as you know that's the
opportunity um i think so most of these
businesses and leases too they don't
offer digital services it is completely
you go in you check the mail that's it
um
and so that would be 90 of them the cool
opportunity i think on top of this is
you buy a business like this you buy a
pack and ship center you input
immediately those another 100 to 200
mailboxes so you've increased your
revenue by a few thousand dollars a
month um with a couple mailboxes that
cost you a couple hundred dollars to buy
and then on top of it maybe you do offer
that service especially in a place like
miami where people are having you know
potentially two locations or going back
and forth between new york and they just
want to make sure that their mail isn't
pioneer piling up you could have a
scanning service in that and charge it a
premium then you might be able to charge
a hundred dollars a month for a service
like that so i think those are
interesting but most people don't do
that
when you think about buying real estate
at auction how does that work
yeah so my friend aaron amuchastege is
amazing at this what what i try to do
and i think what people should think
about doing if they're going to get
multiple income streams you can't be an
expert at everything you know if i want
to go and really understand crypto and
bitcoin i would have to spend hours and
hours and hours and hours or instead i
could follow somebody like you and i am
a subscriber to your newsletter and
every single day i could learn a little
bit more about the asset class and i
could invest alongside you in deals or i
could give you money in deals so that's
typically what i do with all these asset
classes i'm like all right lisa i'm
going to invest in your business over
here mailbox money aaron and muchastegy
i want to go with you and i want you to
teach me how to buy real estate at
auction this is so cool this guy came
from nothing
he has no like formal college degree um
super blue collar and he was doing what
everybody does in real estate which is
just selling houses back and forth he
flipped a few houses and then he found
out about this thing called real estate
foreclosure auctions and he's located in
the state of texas
where they have a um they sell houses on
the courthouse steps so every single
month they release a listing of all the
houses that are going up for foreclosure
and with that listing you can comb
through it and prepare to go on the
courthouse steps and bid on these houses
the amazing part is and even in a market
like this today you are able to buy
houses for let's call it anywhere from
30 to 50 discount to the market rate you
can get actually a higher discount if
you go and knock on the individual doors
themselves to actually buy properties
and so aaron has this whole thing where
you know he's now worth tens of millions
of dollars he's bought thousands of
these houses he now keeps about 250
houses or so
as rentals to cash flow and he bought
them all on the courthouse steps there's
obviously particulars with this like
you've gotta actually you need to do a
little bit of research if you're gonna
do something like this he has a book on
it i think the book's basically free um
he just does it to be a nice guy and
then what i love about this business too
and this is what i talk to more business
owners about doing he owns this real
estate foreclosure business right so
he's out there buying houses at auction
and anybody can show up to these
auctions it's totally free so you can
just go and check it out i've gone with
him it's really cool
but then on top of it he was like how
else could i add value to this main
business and he was like well what if i
took a a sas company that lists all of
the houses that are for sale right now
that's a subscription-based business
that people like him buy what if i
bought that business and then i put some
money into it and then had that business
grow even bigger so he bought his first
sas company and then he's like and then
what if i bought the the company that
goes out and does door knocking to try
to buy businesses beforehand and it has
a sas subscription model to it too
geolocation and stuff like that and then
he bought that company so those are
called roll ups and i get really excited
about that in any industry
ancillary service roll-ups because you
can add one company to your already
existing company and that's the only
time i know people these days like to
say math isn't real but that's the only
time that one plus one actually could
equal three or five with strategic m a
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it